[Musique]
moi les vidéos que je vais voir c'est
des trucs à l'ancienne je peux pas me
masturber on va parler franchement je me
fais un kiff on va parler franchement
mais avec des mots pois quand je me fais
un kiff je vais pas me brer sur un truc
les actrices du moment les machins je
connais même pas leur blaz moi je suis
je suis resté bloqué à l'époque des
tabac cache des
trucs moi je regarde beaucoup de de H
Tha de manga érotique et du coup des
fois il y a des trucs c'est n'importe
quoi et des fois je me dis c'est limite
là je sais pas où j'en suis c'est ce que
cette pieuvre tent avec des tentacul en
forme de bit m'exite vraiment je ne sais
pas tu vois ça va ça va c'est quoi le
plus que vous avez jamais vu parce que
excusez-moi parce que là il y a un
respectect de l'abonné il faut envoyer
la sauce mais sin on aura invité maître
Gims qui nous disent oui maintenant il y
a plus de porno on s'en fout quuc plus
Ding j'is rien allezy pard j'ai vu des
des trucs de soumission sur un ring où
les meufs se les meufs se bastonne celle
qui perd se fait soumettre après ça
c'est chant mais j'ai adoré donc je me
suis fait toute une série de vidéos ou
[Musique]
mortel ma copine y va par exemple tu
vois ma copine se fa fait des vidéos
machin complètement on a une sexualité
une approche complètement décomplexé de
la pornographie sur le net parce que
c'est un truc fait partie de nos vies
quoi
j'ai besoin de de sentir que je sais pas
deux acteurs prennent du plaisir à
baiser ensemble pour m' prendre moi-même
qu en les regardant voilà les trucs de
performance et de les trucs hyper
gymnastique et Machin attends je m'en
fous un peu de acteursas de acteurs
coming out bienvenue chez toi la
maison maintenant il sont tous
dans
[Musique]
moi je pense à ce truc là qui m'a hé
toute toute ma jeunesse et tout ouais
moi j'avais pas le décodeur journal du
c'était le gral c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
C tellement mal crypté on pouvait
regarder le journal du
MO voyait grave bien ça suffisait
largement je pense qu'ils en fais exprès
pour que les gens ça a l'air bien
quand même